so so there's something I can show the
audience right now everybody just take
you take your hand and do a thumbs up do
a little Fonzie okay all right so if you
can just do that and then transfer the
hand to a point okay and then just and
then just go back and forth just go back
and forth okay so it's relatively easy
right just just right back you can drop
those that's your skillet yep okay
easy enough right yeah now take your
other hand with this hand point and with
this hand do the thumb okay now and you
can go as slowly as you want we're going
to switch back and forth like that
Shaboom Oh
Shaboom I feel you're killing it
she is crushing it right here you are
did young everybody looked at her that's
if she do it under pressure she is
crushing it right boom all right yeah
put the bum up and then point and then
flip it and then flip it yeah you're
doing that's it
[Applause]
so we did this we did this on the show
we did this on the show and this is an
example of what scientists call bimanual
interference which is the like a fancy
term for the the trouble that your brain
runs into when you try to do two
different things at the same time with
your hands in particular so I guess if
you're a drummer you're like a genius I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this